[Music]
so since we have eric today i thought
it'd be really cool to uh
talk about some of the most common nft
misconceptions oh yeah help me i don't
know [ __ ] yeah because we have a lot of
stupid questions about it and i'm sure
like maybe in nfts there's no stupid
question but um dumb dude it would be
great to clear up a lot of like popular
things that people get wrong about them
okay yeah you know cool uh i'll start is
there really like a environmental impact
that's like disastrous when it comes to
nfts yeah so that's a good question
right great question guys that's a
really smart question
that comes up a lot so it depends on
what chain chain is basically what
blockchain the nft is built on so
there's a lot of popular ones now solana
is a new one ethereum is one there's
even nfts are built on the bitcoin
network and so the way that that we're
looking at is every transaction that
happens on one of these chains
electricity is being burnt to make that
happen so ethereum network is probably
the biggest
i guess perpetrator of what we perceive
to be environmental impact because it
runs when you validate one transaction
or emit an nft it needs to be validated
across all of these like thousands of
computers around the world and each of
them are burning a little bit of energy
so right now ethereum is on what we call
proof of work network meaning like it
has to be run by computers so each time
an nft is minted or sold that gas fee
that covers a transaction just think of
it as like electricity you can burn all
around the world
but the hope is in the next couple of
months or years ethereum is going to
move to what they call eth 2.0
and that becomes proof of stake so that
means every time a transaction happens
you buy an nft
or you mint an nft or you do a
transaction on ethereum it's not burning
a [ __ ] ton of electricity now it's just
being validated against this like
internal like transaction system but
right now that's like the thing a lot of
people are talking about is like every
transaction and just in crypto in
general bitcoin ethereum each
transaction happens burns electricity
all around the world how much
electricity is that in relative to let's
say like a household like appliance or
something like is it really that much
more than what a person normally uses
yeah yeah it is pretty i don't i don't
remember the exact amount but it is
pretty significant for each transaction
because just imagine there's tens of
thousands of computers validating these
transactions
and each transaction has to be validated
across all the computers so it's all the
electricity everyone's using put
together yeah yeah cause a gas fee could
be like a couple hundred bucks sometimes
you're like what the [ __ ] yeah there's a
point in time when there's um actually a
couple weeks ago hugo labs which created
the board yacht club project there was a
project that they just dropped called
other side land which you know i ended
up minting
it was so hotly contested people wanted
it so bad
that just to pay gas to mint it it was
about two thousand dollars in gas to
mint one
right so if you can imagine the demand
on the network so many people are trying
to hit the network all at the same time
all these miners are validating all
these transactions just imagine how much
electricity is burnt to mint like one of
these like these digital monkey lands
wow i have a question for um
like is there a specific type of
demographic
that's into nfts
that's a good question so like for some
context like i run in accounting and tax
practice and we focus a lot on
nft founders and nft platforms we do
accounting for some of the biggest
players out there when it comes to the
demographics a lot of them are marketing
too they typically are in a younger
generation
like typically it's 18 to 33 year old
type of an individual mostly men and
guys are into
into the nft space there is a small
contingent of women that's starting to
come into it which i think is really
cool but it's usually like younger guys
that are into it because a big like venn
diagram that i see at least on my
instagram is like sneakerheads and nft
is like i don't know if it's like hype
or height beast or whatever but just
seem like there's a huge overlap there
there is a big overlap and that started
happening about fall of last year when
the profits of like flipping jordans
wasn't as profitable anymore so they all
moved over to the nft space and becoming
nft flippers so there is a big
intersection of like the hype beast
sneaker heads in the nft i saw that with
nba top shot and like sneaker heads yeah
so nfts are prime like as i understand
them right now they are basically just
bragging rights more or less and you're
fighting for like that exclusivity of
having this
thing
right it's not but you're not even
owning the like a limited edition
sneaker yeah but it's like literally
just this like digital token right that
you have
ownership of right sort of kind of so
think of an nft as like a irrevocable
proof of ownership of someone yeah
so right now what we're seeing in the
market is we're looking at in terms of
digital art even though like some of
these things if we look at like that's
ugly as hell like that's not art right
so it's a digital token representing you
have exclusive ownership of this
particular thing
but in the near term we're seeing
companies like starbucks using it for
membership cards ibm is investing
billions of dollars into creating nfts
for intellectual property you know we
might see it come out for real estate in
terms of title but right now we're
seeing in terms of okay you're buying it
nfts you're buying a piece of art but
what's the underlying piece behind it so
a lot of folks are buying nfts like
board ape yacht club for example or
um crypto punks because there's a
membership or there's an exclusive
access to a community so we call that a
velven good so developing good is
something that has tangible value above
and beyond what it is so there's no real
difference between like a chanel bag or
a coach bag they just they hold the same
thing right why why are they different
one is more exclusive one has a certain
luxury cache so same thing with nfts
when you have it it's like a flex you
could show people hey i got a boripe
yacht club which is now worth 200 grand
yo this is what i got how do you show it
like on your phone do you show proof
like i'm a member of the yacht board
apes some people they have it on there
they could load it up on their phone you
know
instagram photo people have merged like
twitter has validated um profile
pictures based upon that so there's a
lot of different ways and it's like a
digital flash instagram's going to do
that too right instagram is working out
too yeah what if i like show people my
costco membership is that pretty
exclusive it's
business yo it's the black card y'all
buy a kinja bang in bulk
the exclusive one i mean the executive
one or that's pretty sweet dude
is it a red one or a black i'm jealous
because you could buy the pizza which
now we can't
yeah you have to be a member to buy the
food court stuff yeah even if it's
outdoors yeah even if it's outdoors
lying about his costco membership
on record he's lying always triple a
though five year five-year-old five
years if i get a flat tire that'll come
in three minutes sometimes even sooner
so i'm not with new cars they come with
the thing you don't need aaa
what thing you just call the company's
towing thing that that comes in the
roadside assistance yeah
yeah
yeah that's a new luna dude well it
comes pretty quick though dude like
it depends on no it depends on where you
live it depends on where you are and
when you call them ron was telling me
during our like little naked walks he
was saying that uh
in the tow truck space with roadside
assistance it's usually a contractor
that dispatches to all the tow truck
companies but all of them the number one
priority if they get 20 calls that come
in aaa is the number one he's trying to
get his company aaa certified because
that's when you get most of the jobs
talking straight about triple a over
there that's more worth more than a
board
here's a question how what percentage of
nfts
um on the market do do you believe are
intentional worthless scams and how do
you tell them apart yeah that's a good
question so like in the nft space and in
the crypto space in general we hear this
term called rug pool right rug pulls
basically where somebody creates
something with no intention of actually
building it they take the money and run
so there is a facet in the nft space
where there are a lot of drug pulls like
i've collected over about a thousand
nfts at this point and 700 of them are
complete dog [ __ ]
that's just the nature of the beast
right
it's a lot it's a numbers game it's a
numbers game so there right now there is
an aspect of like people that are
scamming in the space and anytime you
come into an emerging technology just
like in the dotcom.com era back in the
late 90s a bunch of it was complete
garbage right same thing in the crypto
markets the ico space a lot of it was
complete garbage same thing in the nft
space so i personally believe and
there's a lot of other like big players
in space that leave probably about like
98 of the stuff out there is gonna
disappear
but two percent is like gonna be like
the amazons or the apples of the googles
of today
so it is a lot of big numbers and
obviously this is not financial advice
do your own research um
but um there is a lot of scams so you
gotta be careful how do we pick the two
percent
tell us the secrets now
and there's there's really no like big
secrets but it's just like investing and
i use the word investing loosely because
a lot of it is like a gamble but it is
like if you're looking to be an angel
inside of a new company you want to
figure out who the founders are the do
they have a track record of success in
the past right what are their promises
is this realistic
timeline of what they they're looking to
do they call them should we have done
that with doe quan
failed the stable coin once already why
are we even trusting this guy didn't
come out until after yeah oh yeah a lot
of this stuff no no no no one knew
yeah no [ __ ] dough quan dude
it was dough anyway i think something
else i thought we just hate him i just
got him tattooed on my [ __ ] ribs
i love that logo and everything
oh man one of uh one of my friends has a
uh like a v friends nft yeah and then so
um i
i was like that's i don't know what the
whole like like value of it was but i
think with it oh the garyvee one yeah
you can go to his conventions with trump
which are huge which is this weekend
yeah and if you don't have it you can't
even go to his conventions
which is kind of cool
so that's that's a big part of it so
that the easiest way to parallel for
those aren't that are in the crypto or
not in a thesis think of a country club
right the only people that could go to
the country club are the ones who paid
right membership sorry
that's right that's right right
um so like having an nft in certain some
of these projects is like a membership
pass to be part of like this country
club
right so same thing with v friends to go
to one of garyvee's events you have to
have a v friends nft
and it's like it's artist's objective
you look at it it's gary actually
scribbled his own stuff
and you look at this picture of a bear
you're like that doesn't look like a
bear looks like something a
five-year-old kid had scribbled right
but again it's like they're using this
as a token to validate you have
ownership or membership into this
organization and then that's how you get
into these events yeah what do you think
about uh how the food industry's been
adopting nfts with you know like a fly
fish or with a andy nguyen open the
board and hungry restaurant yeah for the
yacht club members yeah so so andy and
his one of his partners kevin good
friend of mine like they've created this
project that we've been launching that's
called food fighters now andy is known
in socal as like the
the food guy yeah right he just sold
after his ice cream and all that stuff
like that i sold it he just said that do
you know how much you sold it for i
don't know i don't know can you find out
right now in columns
um
so it's a white guy huh
probably a country club
yeah
food group they have actors at every
clubhouse now and all the courses
we sold it to kirkland dude i knew it i
knew it proud sponsor of the pga tour
afters
so what their what their project is
doing is they're intersecting the
restaurant space with digital consumers
so what we're seeing is we're gonna see
all these like really interesting and
novel ideas come up and come to place so
their first line and things might have
changed since they first gave me the
white paper but the first line is like
the first layer of folks that come in
they're part of this exclusive club
where they can go to exclusive tastings
and support other restaurants and create
this little ecosystem and then they're
going to launch a bigger project that
the consumers could come into and also
interface with these different
restaurants
so same thing like like garyvee's fly
fish he bought this exclusive like sushi
restaurant and in order to go to sushi
restaurant and rub shoulders with other
digital celebrities and stuff like that
you had to have this membership right
the fly fish nft so that what we're
going to see is we're going to see some
really interesting intersections between
this digital space
and the real world real world space even
starbucks they're looking at changing
their reward system into an nft
and then people go in to validate that
to show that they have the nft to be
able to get certain rewards do you want
to know the best use they could have for
nfts that'd be the most ultimate cash in
you can only edit your drink if you have
an nft
yeah that's something
tell me everybody wouldn't get that yeah
everyone's getting it otherwise you have
to have it as it is but if you're like i
want to have no no the sugar soy bug
please do you have the nft
are you a holder
[Laughter]
now imagine like if you hold an nft and
i'm working with another restaurateur in
socal with this if you hold the token or
the nft and you scan it it unlocks a
secret menu
that only nft holders could have you can
get a frappuccino animal style
pickles
thanks for being a holder
thanks delicious